[Music]
kanye west could not stop smiling during
celebrity family feud
it was the west's
versus the kardashian-jenner x' on
sundays much-anticipated a new episode
of the family game show battling it out
to win $25,000 for the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles and Kanye was
definitely in it to win it
getting every one of his answers correct
and having the best time ever nurse
although team West lost 85 to 497
Kendall and Chloe is sweetly
relinquished their kardashian-jenner
victory round of fast money to let
Kanye's dream of playing become a
reality host Steve Harvey gushed to
Ellen DeGeneres back in April that the
41 year old rapper was his favorite
contestant on the show to date Kanye was
the best Family Feud celebrity panelists
we've ever had in a show he loves the
show yes his people say it Steve this is
the most Kanye has ever smiled the
energy is crazy okay first of all how
did this all happen
well Kim and Kanye have been talking
about you know that they watch Family
Feud every single night and we're all
friends with Steve and Marjorie Harvey
so big big dance and this has been a
dream come true
for all of us
[Music]
[Applause]